I'm here for love and I'm here to have
music bring me together with someone it
is bachelor paradise meets a star is
born but with this eccentric twist
I am very jealous okay I'm a jealous
crazy [ __ ] listen to your hearts coming
for bachelor nation on Monday April 13th
we needed we are so ready for it I'm
really excited because look you know the
bachelor bachelorette on my baby would
be doing it for 18 years but it is this
formula changes from season season but
it's this where is when we got to listen
to your heart it was a blank slate you
had a bunch of characters that didn't
really speak the language and no I mean
there was a guy you'll see episode 1 he
has no idea who I am
I literally had to introduce myself much
less the show and so it was exercising
this different muscle creating a new
show and yes if your bachelor nation it
will feel lovely and familiar but with
this except its eccentric twist gravity
music is so intoxicating it led to a
deeper connection I keep comparing it to
more of a paradise vibe as you said but
what I keep thinking about is unlike
paradise where everybody gets to the
beach and oh I watched you on her season
and oh I saw you on Instagram these
people don't know each other right so
what do you think that affects things
because that's something really new for
the franchise that hasn't happened in
years and years that you just have a
cast of people begin and no one has any
thoughts or awareness I'll be brutally
honest that's one of the toughest things
about television and the scariest thing
about reality TV is having all the
characters that you have to be
introduced to because it takes patience
from you bachelor nation that you have
to sit there and go okay who is Jamie
who's ready who's Chris who's Matt who's
Trevor but I think it makes it fresh it
makes it exciting and it makes these
relationships and there are very strong
relationships super organic and you see
them in the incubation period and you
see the awkwardness and it's fun and
it's uncomfortable as heck the lying and
the
did that happen I told you there was
some emotional she what criticism the
franchise has gotten a past couple of
years is that people are going on just
to get that social media following so
did you find that that lack of awareness
brought more genuine connections because
with this you also have the twist of our
people going on it just to get a career
in music well that's kind of thing you
took the onus off of that it's not about
that because it is about that and so
kind of making it about that kind of
took the pressure off and that it is
about their music but it's about love
and you have to be there to find both
and you'll see that in the show those
that are trying to fake it those that
are just hoping that people won't see it
you do so you just straight-up told
everybody from the beginning you're here
for music and love well actually
straight up in the beginning I said
you're here for love okay music will
come and that is a very important
distinction
you're here because everybody's really
looking for love you're at a place in
your life that you're open to this but
you want to make it in the music
industry well what's interesting about
that is it completely remove what is
often one of the big dramatic focal
points of bachelor/bachelorette which is
are you here for the right reasons
isn't that a discussion on listen to
your yeah because that that is something
that we always fight on the show and we
were really out of it as producers this
has to be about relationships and fellow
and as producers we were able to tailor
the show and create a show that really
drove that in and then yeah there are
musical performances and there will be
people voted off and it has to do with
their performances but it has just as
much to do with the chemistry and their
relationships and you'll see how it
plays out is there the promise of
proposals at the end of course I mean
there's always the hope and the promise
of love and if love is strong enough it
would be a proposal and some maybe more
multiple couples would write off in at
the sunset I mean it's happened in
Paradise multiples multiple couples the
ultimate dream of the show is that at
the end of the day we have one superstar
couple that is the listen to your heart
champion couple and they are deeply
madly in love and there's the Jackson
Ellie that's why we're looking for we're
looking for Bradley lady
look I don't have to preach to the choir
but that moment at the Oscars when
Bradley and Lady Gaga were performing
together and we all thought they could
literally fall on the stage and make a
baby blanket moment that is what we're
trying to create
that's what listen your heart is can you
create that chemistry i wonder if lady
gaga knows that cuz she's a bachelor fan
should tweet it about theater season she
look she needs to know we're all fans
and season two please be a part but no
it is about that and the cool thing is
this was really different
the first stand-up when I've been from
the house I say welcome to listen to
your heart I talked about a star is born
I talk about Lady Gaga Bradley Cooper
it felt really weird because it's so out
of place you've never given it not
something else but in spite like
Bachelor was its own creation so you
guys even not acknowledging something
else on that level is journey honestly
took a page from that script in thought
can we with our bachelor magic create
that we have to talk about something
that's not the same which is that when
you're doing that first stand-up you're
a peach where are you guys
you are at AMS yeah why not the bachelor
mansion opposite your heart two very
specific reasons one the bachelor
mansion is massive as it is it's not big
enough space wise for this because we
need space for performances people just
a lot more space because a lot more
people and on top of that we thought
fresh show fresh look that's our
paradise is somewhere different we
really wrestled with this idea without
know it let's let's go somewhere
different we could have grabbed it into
the to the mansion but we thought let's
let's take it to a different place it's
kind of a ranch with a mansion on on it
and so we got lots of sprawling space
because one of the first performances is
actually on yeah so it works okay we get
rose ceremonies are they similar to
Paris this room service well what do
they work are they similar to paradise
is it men women men picking women with
so it first did his bachelor paradise
we've been voting up men men voting off
women and strongest couple survive then
we get into the performances we have
celebrity judges and also some famous
faces from our bachelor family and they
will decide who makes it out of those
performances but they also realize it's
about the performance in the chemistry
so they are judging the chemistry 100%
that's why we brought in Jojo and Jorden
Rachel and Brian Atari of Lawrence
Katelyn and Jayson they're a part of
this because yeah Jason Mraz and ketchup
and Pat Monahan and Rita Wilson all
these people are brilliant but you know
can they also see that chemistry so we
wanted our people to have an expert on
some people pointed out that it looks
like to listen to your heart finale
seems to now be airing on the night
Bachelorette was supposed to premiere so
does Bachelorette get pushed back months
do you film for a shorter amount of time
what kind of discussions are happening
from the bachelorettes our baby this is
what's paramount to us right now as soon
as we get back the bachelorettes contact
that's the first thing we're gonna do
the deal with listen to your heart is
we're gonna try and extend that and
create as much content as we possibly
can we were rushing to you listen to
your heart on Monday April 13th that we
were crushing hosts apartment now we're
doing this from home so even the version
that I just watched isn't cut it's not
ready to go we it's not ready to air and
so I'm still watching rough versions of
the show it's not even ready to be
consumed yet so again we are doing our
best to get content on and create as
much content as we can but trying to do
it from home like everybody else says
well you guys do that with
bachelor/bachelorette sometimes you pull
one more episode out than you'd intended
to an adjusted step it's not crazy for
ABC to call and say hey episode 4 can
you guys do another hour or whatever and
so that happens quite a bit so yeah it's
not crazy to look deeper into the into
the show and think hey good episode 6
have three hours or whatever so we're
just trying to be creative and trying to
you know leave all the cards on the
table we are gonna get
TBD number of episodes it sounds like
yeah how many are scheduled right now
God poor Chad why he if you just waited
I got a lot of those uh tweets it's me
it's like just missed yeah I think we
invited him all to be a part of it I
think you probably had enough we are
recording this interview on Zoom you
mentioned potentially doing things on
Zoom we want listen to your heart to be
a huge hit it's gonna be I think the
next beloved a bachelor show so could
you do a listen to your hurt
reunion would it be on zoom' there's
definitely potential with that I think
there's a look we're gonna first of all
we can see hopefully everybody loves the
show and they want more but if there is
this appetite for more and we think that
there's enough story there where there's
relationships or whatever it is where it
Garner's a special then yeah unless we
can get people into safely into a studio
you would definitely be done with that
an audience but you know I think we
could zoom could we see listen to your
heart cast members on paradise bring
them in that's off the table we have a
great cast not you guys are about to be
introduced to you on Monday and I think
people are gonna fall in love with them
and connect with them the way they do
back from bats or our contestants and so
maybe that's an interim maybe that's a
way to get to it faster I don't know I
mean I would I guess I sort of spot even
without this pandemic happening that you
could potentially bring listen to our
people into paradise possibly unique
it's a new franchise it's a new
experiment for us and so honestly it's
kind of fun that I'm a little scared to
see what happens Monday night I hope you
all watch I hope you all love it but you
never know but if people resonate and
really pop up that showing I know the
characters and I think they're going to
I could easily see off the top of my
head five six of these people that went
perfectly slide into the backs of the
world okay bring those guitars to the
beach
[Music]